i actually didn't uh move away from
engineering i
upgraded from being an electrical
engineer to a life
engineer it's so much about having that
we forget
living you know living is what life is
for
what's your favorite pizza
today's episode of model monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles i've done over
3
800 split tests which have led to
results like taking this 5 year old
video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail it blew
up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for free
at tubebuddy.com evan there he is
mr gurga paul das how are you i'm good
thank you and how are you doing even
how's
canada are you in canada at the moment
i'm at home canada toronto
everything is uh everything's paid safe
all my friends family's safe so
nothing to complain about here um but
super excited to have you on
if for everybody watching if you don't
know this man
if you want to get wisdom if you want to
be entertained
if you want to learn from what i think
is maybe one of the the greatest
storytellers
of our generation you have to go check
out his channel
and he's also the author of a new book
called the way of the monk
tell us quickly about the concept of the
book why you wrote it
and why people should care yeah uh
thank you very much evan for your kind
words but i must say that you're doing
such great work as well
with your channel and your tagline i
suppose what is believe nation
that's it that's it
you're doing such an incredible job man
so firstly my
uh heartfelt congratulations and
uh gratitude for doing what you're doing
trying to make the world a better
better place so thank you very much
in regards to the book the way of the
monk
it's about 25 years back that i decided
to
make the shift from being an electrical
engineer to a monk
you know in fact a lot of people often
ask me why did you
why did you move away from engineering
and i tell them that i actually didn't
move away from engineering i upgraded
from being an electrical engineer to a
life engineer or a
lifestyle engineer
and i always felt that it was moving
from dealing with machines and systems
to dealing with the human potential
behind the machines and the systems
i was in singapore doing an event
called masters of the century and i
happened to share stage with sofia
the humanoid you know the first
artificial intelligence based robo she
was interacting she had human features
and when she was questioned about
artificial intelligence
she said you humans are the ones who
gave me this artificial intelligence
and she said we as artificial
intelligence driven robots
are not meant to be competing against
the human potential
we are meant to be complementing the
human potential
you know so so i i decided that i'm not
going to work in the field of ai
i'm going to field in the world i'm
going to work in the field of ri
real intelligence
i like that
so move from technology to the human
human mind the human potential that's
how i decided to be a monk
so when i joined the ashram the
monastery i
started learning the ancient wisdom from
my teachers from my gurus from
people around me reading the books
reading the apex
and then i felt as i was living there
i've been there for the
last 25 years now and i felt that
monkhood has very little to do with what
you wear
it has very little to do with your
particular faith
it has very little or nothing to do with
the place where you live whether you
live in a monastery or you live at a
home
or you the demographics the geography
doesn't matter
it it barely has anything to do with
your hairstyles as well and we share a
similar hairstyle
it's close it's
[Laughter]
so monk heard really has little or
nothing to do with these externals
monkhood has a lot to do with the
principles
the values it has a lot to do with your
mindset
therefore in the way of the monk after
every chapter there's a section called
the monk
mindset you know it's that mindset which
can
really transform the way we live it's
that mindset which can transform our
relationships which can transform the
way we grow professionally
it can transform the very experience of
our life
and allow us to tap into the deepest of
our human potential
so after realizing that this monk
mindset is not limited to the boundaries
of a monastery
i thought i must share this you know so
the way of the monk
is trying to share the monk principles
that i learned
in the monastery and bring that to the
world in a way that people can apply
them try to apply them
and see if we can bring a positive
change in life that was the
logic behind writing the work here i'm
so excited for it i think
you know we profile many different monks
on the channel
uh and a lot of times the the message is
a little hard
to understand and what you do so well is
make it easy to understand
and make it fun at the same time i try
man
[Laughter]
i mean in your videos there's laughing
there's storytelling it looks like
you're having fun
in the process even when it's talking
about something very serious and and
obviously helping people what do you
think is the
you know most people who read the book
won't go become a monk and join an
ashram so
what do you think is the the biggest
thing that we're missing
that the average everyday non-monk
person needs
that can they can benefit from the monk
mindset i think what's happening a lot
with our lives today
is that we're living in a very
fast-paced life
life has become very fast achievements
social media statuses you know how what
sustainable status and social media how
we achieve in our professional life
it's so much about having that we forget
living you know and life is not meant
simply for having having is a part of
life
correct but living is what life is for
but in the process of having in chasing
to have
more we forget to live well
you know and therefore when we're
talking about this monk principles or
we're talking about this monk
mindset we're talking about making that
choice and prioritizing
to live well and we're gonna talk when
we talk about living well we talk about
making those choices we choose to live
well
we choose to do things and i feel that
one of the greatest assets
that each one of us has been gifted with
is the power to craft our life to choose
to craft our life
to choose to uh sculpt our life
we are the architects of how our life
should be but unfortunately
we live so much in the default mode like
it's funny you know when we're talking
about our iphones
we don't keep our ringtones in the
default mode
we customize them when we wear clothes
we don't wear clothes that come in the
default mode we customize them
even our pizza topics we customize them
so it's quite funny that we as human
beings
customize practically everything we have
and do
but we live our life in the default
setting without customizing it
you know each one of us is different
each one of us has a different
situation in life each one of us has
different backgrounds different baggages
we carry
and it's so crucial and important to
customize a life that's worth
living you know so one thing that i
definitely want to say people who are
not going to go to the ashram and nobody
needs to bangkok is not about being in a
national
definitely need to look at prioritizing
how to customize their life and that's
then about making those choices
what do you put on your pizza what's
your favorite pizza
you to tell me yours personal answer
event
uh i like a lot of cheese and a lot of
meat so
it'd be like lots of pepperoni and extra
cheese
okay for me i like pesto sauce
i like uh pizza pizzas with the pesto
sauce and i like uh
jalapenos i like you know uh
fresh olives nicely fresh olives i also
love artichoke hearts
toppings on my pizza but more than pizza
we need to customize our lives for sure
so if anybody if anybody's buying you a
pizza they know they know what to order
now
um why why do we not customize their
lives why do we feel like we can't is it
that
we're worried about our parents or or
our teachers
or our culture or the people in our
lives like why
why would we customize our phone in a
second
but then when it comes to our lives we
feel like i can't do that
yeah yeah i think it has a lot to do
with being affected by
the noise around us you know there's so
much
noise around us the education system is
noise
you know our upbringing often is noise
how you how we kind of comply with the
social media standards of being
acceptable and being cool
to the world out there is noise and in
trying to
comply with all that noise we forget to
listen to our own voice
you know so we're so much conditioned to
doing things the way
the world does it there are standards of
what is success the standards of what is
cool
that standards of what's socially
acceptable but
but is your life cool have you chosen to
live that way
or is that noise and that influence
making you live that way and most often
if not always
it has a lot to do with that influence
correct
so i i'm not saying education is wrong
i'm not saying our upbringing
or the advice given by our family or our
friends or our well witches is wrong
i'm just saying we cannot drown in that
noise
and lose ourselves it's our life it's
our life they're not going to live it
for us
you know all those people who accept us
because we show ourselves in a certain
way on social media
don't really come there when we need
them the most so sometimes i say we
prioritize our online relationships so
much that we forget our offline
relationships the real ones
you know when if i meet with an accident
if i'm if i'm ill
if i have an issue with my my
financial issue whatever issue are a
problem you know
people online they're good they're good
those friends on facebook and instagram
people who follow they're good
absolutely good and with all good
intentions
the most they can do is send you a
message
the most they can do is send you a
bouquet of flowers
you know get well soon messages and
they're great because they're sent with
love and intentions good intention
they're great but people who are going
to be
there around us are the real people the
real relationships
but in being accepted on social media
and being accepted by the social
standards of success
which i call noise we get so drowned in
that noise
that we forget our voice so that's a
conditioning event you know that we got
so
conditioned to live like that that we
don't now want to customize
which basically means we have to come
out of the shell to come out of that
loop
we have to crack that condition and
crack that loop
and that's when we can choose to
customize
talked about the education system uh you
know kids are going back to school in
north america
right now if
day one of of every school
was gorgeous day
and they you get to be in front of the
kids for the whole day
for one day for every school across the
world
what's what's the lesson that you're
teaching or what are you going to do for
that one day
to touch all everybody's lives
yes uh if i get to be in front of every
kid
in every school in the world even
the one thing that i would like to teach
or tell the students
who are listening to me is that we
cannot go
on extreme sides of the spectrum
one extreme of the spectrum is
follow your passion be yourself correct
which is what i primarily teach as well
like what albert einstein said
you cannot judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree
right you know you can't judge a fish by
its ability to climb a tree judge by
just the fish bites ability to swim in
the water okay
now two things happen in that case
number one the fish is effective
in doing what it can do because it's in
its right habitat
and number two it's satisfied because
it's in the right habitat
correct put a monkey in the water the
monkey is miserable put a fish on the
tree the fish is miserable
put a monkey on the tree the monkey
achieves excellence put a fish in the
water the
fish achieves excellence so i am one of
the proponents i am a proponent of this
principle that we must definitely
encourage our kids to follow their
potential and follow their passion
what happens often is we go on such an
extreme end of the spectrum
that the other side what the education
system has to offer is there are many
good things in the education system as
well
so if i were to talk to the students i
would say let's find that balance
finding best of both the words you know
grab
the best out of what you can have from
the education system
and let the education system also foster
a culture
and ethic and ethos you know where we
allow kids to be who they are
yeah i like it i think we gotta make
that happen
day around the world
for one day i think that'd be great
of course i'd say all of this in the
form of a story of course no i mean
that's great
your stories are what what makes it
happen i love it how do you help people
what do you recommend people do to
figure out if they're the monkey or the
fish
or the whatever like how do you find
that thing because it may not be
what your parents are doing or what your
friends are doing
uh you know the i'm sure the pressure
for you to go be
the engineer was great and then to say
no i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna
i'm gonna be a monk like how do you how
do you
how do people find that thing how do you
recommend when there's a lot of family
pressure on them
how did they find the thing i find a lot
of times it's an issue with the
system okay like for example
the industry the corporate world
is only picking up people from the top
rated universities
the industry is only picking up students
who have the best grades
now if you have people who are being
picked up based on your university or
based on your grades and your marks
and your academic performance then
guess what parents are going to put
pressurized kids with
you better get the marks you better get
the grades you better get to the best
university
okay and guess what the educational
institutions do
it's a demand and supply system if this
if the demand
of the industry's grades and the parents
are pushing to get grades the
educational systems are driven to
make kids get grades now imagine if the
industry changes and the corporate world
redefines saying we don't
hire graves we hire passion
we hire kid we hire candidates for their
passion
okay now what are the parents going to
say don't worry about the great sun
look at your passion and what is the
education system going to provide
how to look at your passion okay it's uh
at the end of the day it's about the
demand and supply really
you know so in terms of how does a kid
or how does an individual
figure that out for himself or herself
number one is there is a voice from
within us
correct and there's a voice from within
us that's constantly resonating with our
soul saying
i love this you know i may be great at
it or i may not be great with it either
or whichever way
but i love this i'm in absolute love
with this
i can wake up early in the morning to do
this and i can go to bed like
late in the night if i were doing this i
know that that's what it's
really in sync with my soul you know now
what happens with that is sometimes it's
multiple things
it's three four five different things
for people
right and now that be the case that be
the case
then i think it's also over a period of
time we need to funnel it down to narrow
it
down to that one thing it's like it's
like being in love
right a guy or a girl is in love with
somebody there's three four different
people they're trying and seeing and
they're kind of exploring
but it's one person who like really
really
strikes that card so one thing is to
listen to your inner conscience
constantly people who are not
in tune with their inner radar are not
going to be able to find out what their
passion is if you're living in life only
catering to the outside demands and not
introspecting
not going deep to listen to your
conscience and you're in your voice
where's the question of figuring out
what the passion
you have to see what number two
is it's not just about what i think i
love
you know i must also have the potential
to develop that
like i may love singing but i may not
have a voice at all
right so you need that element in you as
well
so that element we can figure that out
based on people who
observe us closely it could be our
family our friends
it could be uh well wishers our guides
and often it could even be experts in
that field who can see
and identify that hey okay here's he
feels he loves it but she loves it
but there's also the element in this
person which can be fanned
which can be triggered and it can kind
of turn into a burning inferno
you know of excellence now
in having said that the one issue that
often comes is the family isn't it
that's what you brought up
like when i be when i turned to be a
monk it wasn't an easy thing
if at least if i moved from being an
engineer to something else in the
corporate world was still pie
you can imagine my extreme choice
giving up a white corner he looked back
our job to be a monk
wearing robes and painting your face and
staying in a monastery
sleeping on the floor so it's kind of a
little weird
but i think i think what it is
is it when we stand up for ourselves
when we stand up for ourselves then when
we are strong
about what we want to do and something
that's burning within us
right we may not be able to do it
instantly
we may not be able to do it instantly
people are not able to follow their
passion straight away often
due to several reasons due to family
objections due to
financial liabilities where they need to
attend to a
regular job to really take care of their
financial liabilities and it's important
it's violent to say that everybody
should follow their passion it's real
it's a reality
but there are real life situations which
need to be attended to as well
so i often say do not do not uh
neglect your passion you may postpone it
correct so my suggestion often is you do
whatever is the mainstream
and you follow your passion side by side
correct let your passion overtake the
mainstream thing that you do
let your family see the advantage let
your family see the benefit
correct let them be able to see that
even this works
so slowly and steadily if it grows
organically
you're in a better position to explain
to them because now you have results
otherwise without results most families
are worried that what's going to happen
to this guy you know
he wants to be a social media influencer
in a time
where it's so bloody hard to be a social
media influencer
the cutthroat competition in the online
world today is
massive humongous right so in that kind
of
space if somebody says i want to make a
living out of this
the first question that family is going
to have as well how are you going to do
that look at the million people out
there
so why not start small you have
something that you do as a mainstream
and start small
and possibly this could overtake and
then what a beautiful life that is
the passion and profession are the same
the next accent yeah for sure
i'm wondering how long did it take for
you after you made the jump for your
your family to accept the decision
oh and that wasn't an easy thing at all
i think it probably was like
maybe five to seven years maybe 10 years
they were supportive of it it's not that
they weren't supportive they were okay
with it
but they were not too happy about it and
then as they saw the work i was doing
you know then they started realizing
that he's doing something tangible
right and especially in the last three
or four years when the social media
journey kind of
uh took off well you know that's when
they realize that he's actually
contributing and doing something
tangible for the world so
so yes everybody who's listening and
everybody's going to listen to this
it's not an easy and immediate
acceptance guys
it takes a while before people who are
close to us
can understand us and sometimes they may
not even understand us further life
but again i must say it's not them who
are going to live our lives
it's we who need to live our lives but
the only
asterisk conditions apply to what i'm
saying
is that when there are financial
liabilities and there are serious
situations at home
i think we should take this entire
principle with a pinch of salt
we can't be like you know really
straight away say this you know families
where there are so many serious
situations and people won't be able to
do what they want to do
straight away so don't don't neglect it
just postpone it
i think there will be a time when one
can follow it fully
if somebody is new so back back to the
book called the way of the monk
if somebody's new to spirituality
think of somebody in north america who
you know hasn't come across a monk
before
might think it's kind of crazy or weird
or different
what do you think is the biggest lesson
the biggest takeaway you want them to
take
if they pick up the book and read it in
the book i talk about
the analogy of a car and
all of us have a journey we have a
destination to reach
we have a journey to take and often
i don't know how it's in canada toronto
but often if you're here in mumbai india
you're stuck in traffic
[Laughter]
so often you see you get stuck in life
like you get stuck in the traffic you
know i want to reach there
you know you're in the training but you
feel stuck you feel stuck in your
personal life you feel stuck in your
profession
you stay still stuck in your
relationships you feel stuck
in your mental health you feel stuck and
there's nothing
worse in life than feeling stuck
even i don't think you've been to bombay
india but if you ever come to bombay
you will get the firsthand experience of
what it means to be stuck in traffic
it's an amazing city i love it i can't
think of living anywhere else in the
world
but traffic wise man it's insane right
now when you're stuck the feeling is
horrific it's just so frustrating
even if you're moving at a small at a
slow pace
but you're moving in the right direction
it's satisfying
correct so i always say if you are stuck
somewhere don't worry you're not a tree
your feet not roots you know nothing
against roots and trees
but roots trees with roots cannot move
we as human beings were feet literally
and figuratively as well
can move on in life so in this analogy
of the car i talk about
the car having four wheels the first
wheel being our personal life
the second wheel being our relationships
the third wheel being a professional
life
and the fourth wheel being a social
contribution
but the steering wheel is our
spirituality
correct so our personal life our
relationships our social contribution
our professionalism
can all be impacted tremendously
by being spiritual and what does it mean
to be spiritual
what does it mean to be spiritual
essentially there's so much we can say
about it
but essentially it's to really try to
move
just from being in the outside world
you're in the world as well
correct it there has to be a good
balance
of the outside and the inside correct
now what's happening is we live so much
in the outside
that we don't connect deeply to
ourselves we don't connect deeply to our
souls we don't connect deeply to our own
true selves
the spirituality means to begin that
journey
of going within right the journey
outside is anyways on
but the more we deeply connect to
ourselves we feel empowered
to deal with these other wheels which is
the personal side the relationships
our professional life our social
contribution everything we feel
empowered to do what we do
so yeah in one line it's really kind of
deeply connecting to yourself
i love it so so that's the steering
wheel and the and the wheels
what's the engine of the car
oh man if the engine of the car is not
in the book
but i would say the i would say the
engine of the car is your
spirit to live life
your passion your gusto your spirit
your strong desire to live life well is
the engine
because without the engine there's no
point the car doesn't function
so unless you want to live well you
don't look at
your personal life you don't look at any
of this we don't even look at
spirituality
but when you want to live well then all
of these things can
definitely fall in place i love it i
love it so much the book is called the
way of the monk if people want to pick
it up
where are they going amazon i mean yeah
it's available
yeah it's it's available on amazon it's
available
at barnes and nobles it's available i
don't know how it's in canada but in the
usa it's available barnes and nobles and
it's available
at indiebound it's available practically
in all bookstores
and definitely on amazon yeah so for the
youtube audience
we'll put all that in the description
below go go check it out go check out
the book
google paul das man thank you for the
love the energy the wisdom of the time
appreciate you and so pumped to get my
hands on the book too
thank you so much evan for having me
over for this conversation
and i love you and i love the work you
do and i
i suppose you wrote the book uh built to
serve
right and i did you were meant to send
me a copy and we've been trying to
do that but because of the pandemic it
hasn't happened is it available in india
i want to pick it up
we've sent some we'll get another copy
after you for sure we'll get another
copy after that
it's been a little delayed with covert
but i'm gonna have the copy
but thank you it's not just you're
writing the book but you're serving the
world in such an amazing way
by putting out this quality content so
absolutely amazing thank you for doing
that
and thank you for having me over here
thank you bye if you want to change your
life for the next 30 days for free
check the link right here below me or if
you want to see the top 10 i did on
gorgo paul das check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there